the largest Christmas market in northern
Germany and a Dane in the middle Rostock
smear Klaus Rua Madson now I can open
the Christmas market in five minutes I
hope it's around the corner before I get
into trouble I'll go ahead and their
Santa Claus - er hello would you be
saying something later
now say something spontaneously I don't
have anything prepared main thing is to
say something like no that was stock
Christmas market is open ok ok it's it's
my office calling probably nervous about
whether I the mayor marched unprepared
to the opening and the Town Hall is
worried no big deal I'm here with Santa
Claus couldn't have a better advisor the
Town Hall isn't used to his relaxed
manner yet German bureaucracy meets
Danish off handedness that's why the
election was a test of courage firm but
voters and Rostock he believes also were
courageous Rostock can be proud to be
the first big city in germany with a
foreign mayor which proves how
cosmopolitan Rostock is it's cool when
people say hey we're about the content
not the passport home didn't pass you
won't find large files in his desk
Copenhagen is his role model like the
Danish metropolis Rostock is to become a
bicycle city there's gonna have space
out there to create something really
intelligent you can weave us into like
in this course also that coming or
happen we could have an idea competition
or something for a bicycle-friendly
downtown in politics close to citizens
this is how Rostock wants to counter the
political trend towards right-wing
populism which Mattson experienced
himself as I skipped on there are a few
who write to me directly about things
they don't like is that head ain't right
no IDs well there are a little more to
the point for example well there's a
comment or two about the fact that I'm
not German nice dog food
[Music]
back to the Christmas market and it's
not a home game Matson was previously a
furniture dealer and not a master of
ceremonies a something so dear children
I'm supposed to open the Christmas
market is that cool cool I think that's
mega cool if I were not mayor I would
like to be Santa Claus why because he
only has to work once a year yeah he was
elected because voters believed he would
be able to tackle the unwieldy German
administration that he is Danish is seen
by some as an advantage but not by
everyone it's a change you have to be
willing to accept change I don't know if
Austin is ready for that you can't just
say German or foreign I think it's a bit
silly but it doesn't have a German
passport I don't really understand that
there are people who have two passports
German and another I don't know why he
doesn't got a German passport belt on
I'll stick to it I have my Danish
passport and no other and I think that's
right why because that's a fact if
someone was born in Germany and moves to
London he doesn't become an Englishman
the new job as mayor can have its
pitfalls
he's trouble finding the entrance for
his next appointment finally he's led in
a discussion in high school on the topic
of education
and dynamic though estimate in Denmark
eighth graders get grades for the first
time here it's stressed from the second
grade what kind of grades do Pater and
Hans have I don't even know the names of
all these daily exercises and tests
examinations
it's insane when it comes to education
the Germans can certainly learn from the
Danes they're far ahead as far as the
christmas markets are concerned
according to Mary Madson Rostock is the
best